[Music]
[Applause]
look i'm keeping woj you know waiting
here he's got more important things to
do adrian wojcinerowski espn senior nba
insider who if they called right now
would you hang up the phone to take that
call woj
uh any number of individuals
well not not that many i mean
which one would you know
let's say it had to do with um
durant donovan mitchell kyrie yeah
anybody else so i i don't think there's
anybody who's
gonna call me this morning that would
um
be engaged in a trade of any of those
guys i think all of those are
slow moving
processes so i don't think there's
anything that would be imminent
on any of those fronts
right now i think after eight and
you know after the action yesterday with
deandre and
signing the offer sheet getting it
matched almost immediately
uh i think there may be i mean sometimes
these are famous last words around nba
free agency and deals but
i don't sense there's anything that's uh
in the short term offing among the the
big names you just mentioned
deandre ayton's signing means what to
the other free agents
well the other you mean the other
players who might be traded right yeah
i'm sorry yeah yeah that's okay but it's
it's almost like perpetual free agency
it's like the transfer portal
in the nba
uh
i think it's harder
for phoenix not impossible but i do
think it's much harder for them
to get involved than a kevin durant deal
i i don't think brooklyn necessarily had
an interest in
doing a silent trade where they would
have gotten eaten and then extended him
but there would have been perhaps
scenarios where ayton
could have gone somewhere else and it
would have moved another asset to
brooklyn that maybe they were more
interested in
uh so
now you look at phoenix and you can't
trade deandre and now you can't trade
devin booker they weren't going to trade
devon booker but
and then you look down the roster mikael
bridges is an outstanding young player
cam johnson's a good young player
they've got they've got picks
that's
that may not be enough to kind of
deliver the massive package that
brooklyn wants for kevin durant
and i don't know if it's posturing and
you'd certainly know better than i would
but i still feel like kevin durant
starts the season in brooklyn am i am i
way off base here it's it's a very
distinct possibility i think especially
because he's got four years left on his
deal kyrie irving is still under
contract
for another year
that they don't just have to go do a
deal that they don't love and they don't
love anything that's out there
right now and
you know i think for teams who would
trade for a player like kevin durant
what you're balancing is
if we gut are in for if we just kind of
gut our team of picks and good players
and we bring kevin durant in are we
necessarily closer to a championship or
do we have kevin durant but not enough
around them there's a balance there
and brooklyn wants to get back
as much as anybody's gotten back for
anybody and so they can keep that
posture right now
because the season's still a ways away
and he's under contract and
and so yeah i do
then think that it's
conceivable that he's back or at least
you know maybe at the start of training
camp but these things can change quick
they can they do
but i think right now
the marketplace is you know there's
miami has a difficult time miami is
another team that would very much like
kevin durant but they're limited in the
deals they can do bam out of bio can't
go to brooklyn if ben simmons is on the
roster because they both have those
um designated rookie max extension deals
you can't have two of those on a roster
so that means you've got to kind of move
pieces around to
and it it's made it more complex to get
a deal done toronto
uh toronto and brooklyn
toronto has had knowing they've shown no
inclination that they would put scottie
barnes the rookie of the year
in any deal with brooklyn i don't think
brooklyn's interested
in talking to toronto about much beyond
um
much about any deal that didn't include
scottie barnes now that's today could
that be different
a week or a month or five months from
now of course it could change i think
that's where they are
today
in in mid-july
i've asked four different nba insiders
analysts on the show and all four didn't
have a reason or an answer for the
following why does kevin durant want out
of brooklyn
i i don't i'm not going to try to speak
for kevin durant i i don't think he's
shared that with
certainly hasn't shared it publicly
i i think
in a very broad sense
i think part of the reason he's as i
think part of it is
he hasn't liked how it he hasn't liked
how it's gone he didn't like how this
year went
um
but
yeah to sit here and say
there's one reason it's this
i think there's a lot of factors that
always contribute to these things and
i think he's going to have to speak to
it i i don't want to
i i don't want to try to speak for for
him on it i think he's going to have to
at some point
um i would think at some point he's
going to
address that but i i just think um
it's been a disappointment and
you know again just signed a new
four-year deal
uh this year
you know i think golden state winning i
think part of it there's
i think part of it there's a part of it
that i think is the criticism that's
come with golden state winning the
timing of the warriors winning and then
people sort of looking back at the
decision kevin durant made okay
and and who he came to brooklyn with and
how that's gone i think they're all
factors in it but
guys do change their minds thinking
evolves it goes back and forth that's
the nature of this stuff and
again because he's under contract
for so long i do think time is on the
net side to try to figure this out
donovan mitchell it feels like
they're open for business with donovan
mitchell does donovan mitchell want to
leave utah
i think donovan mitchell understands
the nature of the business where the
jazz
i think knowing that they kind of
felt like they kind of peaked with the
roster they had
and understands that he kind of sees the
direction they're going so i don't think
he's resisting
uh
the fact that
he's in talks i think he just
understands this is the reality of it
and
you know i think those are not good
enough right now and
danny ainge has shown i think with a
deal he got for rudy gobert
you can see the potential in utah of
having the kind of
uh
pool of draft picks that oklahoma city
had you got essentially five for gobert
if you want to count
um
walker kessler who was their number one
pick this year
but i think you're gonna you would get a
lot for
you would get picks in players for
uh
donovan mitchell and you look around the
rest of their roster there's other guys
if you started trading off
and they could be in position to just
reboot the whole thing
so i yeah i think he's accepting of
the reality of where the organization is
with stuff we're talking to woj uh
adrian wojnarowski espn senior nba
insider i want to be fair to you and it
feels like if i ask you these that you
don't want to speculate because even
when you speculate then people might
misconstrue that as being news or a
report so
that's right yeah so i i know you're
cautious in doing this and i respect
that um i just the sense of and and it's
hard to ask it without wanting an answer
from you
um
you know just so it doesn't become wode
says
uh it's not woj you know speculates but
even then it's going to be new so i i
want to be fair and i want the audience
to know that as well whatever it is dan
you could just ask all right thank you
all right so uh the lakers do what
before the end of this uh be uh for the
start of the season
i i think the lakers still try to add
another guard
another guard who can shoot
uh who can be a playmaker
you know buddy healed in indiana is
somebody they've had interest in they've
talked the pacers on him eric gordon and
houston both of whom
also are former rob polenka clients when
he was an agent so he knows them
particularly well kind of knows what he
gets with them
i i think those are realistic and then
it's
you know the kyrie irving
they did touch base with the nets on it
there's really not been an ongoing
dialogue on that i think
brooklyn i think is dealing with a
durant situation first
and um and so
the price would be much less to try to
and
you're not necessarily those aren't
necessarily westbrook trades either
with the other two um so i do think
there's a chance they could do something
like that they could also do nothing
but i i think
the lakers will also have an opportunity
because they have their picks
once the season starts there's going to
be trade possibilities so they don't
have to gas
those assets right now
but i i
again it may not be what all laker fans
are hoping for which is kyrie irving
but
buddy heel there gordon those are good
players and they would conceivably help
the team so i think those are
realistic trade possibilities that those
are guys they've been
engaged on there i'm sure there's going
to be others that they're checking in on
i know those two specifically and both
of those teams are in rebuilds indiana
houston so
they're okay they're looking you know
they'll move those players if they can
get back
you know kind of whether you know
whatever the pick
uh
whatever it is draft pick-wise they
would like to get from l.a
uh woj thanks for spending time as
always we appreciate it and uh next time
maybe speculate so we can get like a
wodge bomb out of this i could get some
publicity that'd be kind of nice
you got it have a great weekend guys
appreciate it thank you that's it adrian
i don't know if woage picked up on that
i i meant that okay yeah sarcastic
anyway see you all right back to the
phones yeah have a great day